you
for years our world has been at peace
that something is coming I can feel dark
forces are upon us
find these beasts or whatever they are a
world is dying there is nothing to go
back to if our people are to survive we
must make a whole media whenever happens
what happens if we do not unite our
world will perish this doesn't need to
happen
there is one who may help us
firk works there is no other life of war
no but with the humans help there could
be
ye to save all people can we trust him
the beasts they should all be destroyed
are you sure of that
we'll protect to keep you and I you
decide with a humorous against your own
kind
is the suicide we have no choice we
should attack with full force whatever
you plan to do do it now
you
it has begun war is coming so ie to save
all people we must fight together can we
trust him
they're beasts they should all be
destroyed are you sure of that
we'll protect the kingdom you and I we
will try my friend
Warcraft rated pg-13
Warcraft rated pg-13 dark forces are
upon us our world is on the edge of war
its death to all things so are you here
to save our people we must fight
together for orcs there was no other
life but war but with the humans help
there could be
can we trust him they're beasts they
should all be destroyed you sir about
that how come we start with the humans a
good phone card this is suicide and I'm
sure it stays
we'll protect a kingdom you and I we
will try my friend
Warcraft the beginning it has begun
war is coming if we do not unite our
world will perish
you might wanna head over big man well
then I better get going
we'll protect the kingdom with this
Warcraft rated pg-13 our world is dying
there is nothing to go back to if our
people are to survive we must make a
whole media